what do you want you when you grew up I
have had as a planing of you I'm a bug
speeding I'll be asking why people gave
up on urges
[Music]
all is its rim job when you were a kid
when I was a kid I wanted to be a chef
are you a chef now I'm a blues Studies
major that looks no sense to me what do
you wanna be when you grew up a taxi
driver my dream job was being a lawyer
well you now interaction design our UML
I am NOT a lawyer now
do you even drive a car no I cannot
drive so what was your dream job when
you were a kid so like most kids I
wanted to be an astronaut I wanted to be
an astronaut a little astronaut now no
I'm actually a yoga teacher now I make a
mediocre instructors I'm still trying to
figure it out well I wanted to be an
architect was I even me architects would
design buildings that's all I need to
hear sir why I lost interested in uh
what I wanted to kick that flick excuse
I research Amish women and
ultra-orthodox women they're trying to
put me at sleep why did you give up your
dream I didn't really give up on my
dream it just sort of changed so James
all the newer I wanted to be a dancer
and I was a kid dancer now
congratulations
but you are beautiful when you grew up
there when I was a kid and
one of them was the attack see try so
you'll talk taxi driver now I never did
become it was the dream when I was much
younger and dreams change as you go
through different things do you have any
other dreams I have a million dreams I
think you can reach your dream I'm glad
that you said that it gives me more
confidence
[Music]